as we all know the Karen's Cup is coming
up which is the pair of the Sinquefield
cup with the all women's field and black
is actually one of the strongest female
players of our time was it jicama hello
everybody this is Grandmaster than is
borscht and this is puzzlers paradoxes
everyone's favourite alright so let's
start let's start the puzzle one londa
who's a famous Russian grandmasters
playing the equally famous he'll our
person Tiger who's famous for the tiger
modern now he made a sacrifice on d4 and
the big question is here if it's sound
or not white to move and win so can we
take with the pawn no so that's out of
the question what else can we do we can
take with the knight and the bishop one
of them will be good one of them being
less good yes back there so I have yes
ok ok so ok that's great
it's a good point but you have to
calculate one move is not enough so
you're claiming that Knight takes is
good but if you believe it prove it yes
okay okay all right you have good points
that you feel that 90x is better or
bishop ticks which one the bishop take
is better mm-hmm but we still don't know
exactly if the knight takes is good or
not we need proof this game is just
about proving your point
how good is Knight takes objectively yes
no no long-term philosophical answer is
good I want facts
so Knight X let's take how would you
play with black that's the question
okay Bishop takes can I take the pawn
not really because the Queen would take
me in that's not good so Bishop takes
now the question is if this is winning
for white or not you have an idea no
okay yeah so why do you have to take on
c1 first why do you have to take here
yes we check so that's very important
because of this white is winning but
because of the move order black can
start with taking first take takes no
checks I mean even if you check I can
take you so it's not a big deal and he
takes obviously doesn't work because of
the same good old queen taxi to trick
okay so now we know that Knight takes d4
is not good but we have to prove the
other one okay yes yes
so Bishop takes d4 that's what you're
saying
and now be sure take Z for you sad or ok
wrote miss ship takes a night takes if I
take that rook take C it is the same
thing and takes takes we win but the big
question is obviously book takes e1 this
is the main idea of black sacrifice on
d4
yes and the key is taking with the night
and that's what lamda found because if
white takes on c1 you can just take on
d4 takes takes and we're back on track
this is good for black so now I think c1
saves the day and loses for black
because after takes takes this night
defense the Queen that was the point
good job now here you're getting
attacked who's black but like as a good
defense here 98 check is being
threatened but sometimes the best
defense is attack and this position is
no different
nice where yeah my page three check very
good
now what if I move my king in the corner
what will happen then
yes
yes so if they don't react we'll just
keep on checking until it's all cleared
for our queen and then checkmate I mean
not yet but just for the fans Knight f2
is a nice little smother checkmate
diesel although there's one more thing
that we need to see and as G takes h3
yes and and this just wins the Queen
correct and the Queen drops yeah ok
other puzzle so this game was played
between kuzmina the courtship courtship
is not a well-known Russian player but
he is also very strong not as well known
as Koosman who was very good and I think
he was top hundred if I'm correct and
actually they're playing this in the
Soviet championship of 1976 it's white
to move and win
seemingly in this position black is out
of danger in fact seems to be almost
winning because both the bishop and the
Queen is hanging yes okay I take your
queen
and then
okay all right yes okay rook takes the
Queen King h8 okay
okay I take you all right let's go there
so D takes is six yeah we'll get there
d take C six years this must be the
critical move that's correct
runs correctly that takes takes here f8
take you I try not to resign yet
yeah so it's close but not quite there
question is how to do it is this the
correct solution probably D takes at
least D takes looks very promising here
yes very good what's the point of Bishop
b2 yeah
pin the bishop and what can black do
them yeah basically he cannot resign but
if he's still desperate and tries not to
lose what would be the only move here
yeah
well if you take I clean with made no
but you can still fight with one more
move that doesn't lose immediately rooks
III I can still take but it it should be
a blockading move that's true yes Queen
before then I Queen and I made yeah
d 8 I can still queen so our main issue
is this Bishop on b2 right so we need to
block it somehow how can we convenient
well I shouldn't say conveniently block
it because there's no convenient way of
blocking it but at least we could try
yes
b5 what but it's black to move
yeah rook d1 that's not blocking this
diagonal but I also I can just queen and
mate yes yeah yeah sorry pawn what what
is that
open eight six mm-hmm but we're trying
to block this Bishop from pinning black
yeah yes even though this is still
losing because we know the winning move
here right yeah just Bishop takes and
has to resign now but when you're
playing a game it's very important to
make it as hard as possible for your
opponent that's why I wanted to show
this rug d4 move because one mistake is
enough if your opponent takes you might
be able to take the check and something
might happen so try to force your
opponent to fight and find the best
moves possible and you're obviously
black resigned because it's just losing
them and this game is interesting
because as we all know the Karan's Cup
is coming up which is the pair of the
Sinquefield Cup with the all women's
field and black is actually one of the
strongest female players of our time was
it Chicana so we're actually going to
play in her shoes so actually try to do
it so it's her to move and win seemingly
she's in a big trouble cuz the bishop
and the Queen is double attacked but she
finds a very creative tactical idea here
which will save the game and even win it
for her
so it's black to move and win yeah
should be four but if I take your queen
look to see it then I take on c5 yes
it's actually not that easy
what musici comes up in this position is
very very nice actually a very tricky
idea by her
but I give you a hint you must do
something with your queen you need that
Queen to checkmate in this position yes
yes
yeah but if you take I take here I take
you and I take everything so this is not
too good so we need to preserve that
Queen for later
mating action yeah something if I take
cream cheese if I play rugby - if I play
group CC - I'm fighting I'm fighting
and I bring my queen into defense as
well yeah it's just too many pieces so
you need to act a little bit more
drastically but your first move might
actually be the best 187 might be the
best one just you need to try a
different idea the upcoming moves so
Queen e7 is the first move Bishop takes
e5 just we will need to go for a more
radical solution here but black yes
Queen g5 well probably I have to defend
my bishop
yeah so not this one
yes oh never mind okay
so somewhere here we have a very very
good solution for block yes this your
page to page three very interesting can
probably play something like rook d2
interesting probably kingi one
yeah so we're close here but black has
to be really precise as we saw from the
previous examples we cannot just attack
bit we have to go all out to save or
even win the game yeah rook take is g2
and I take u g5 King f1
I'll go rogue d2
this again doesn't look enough so
probably we need some more pieces to
attack right because we were only using
either the rook or the queen or the wavy
that it was a bit slow so we need to
play a bit more forcing Lee to actually
get there with the attack how can our
play become even more forcing because
whenever we sacrificed something it was
never a check it's actually a problem
yes yeah Queen h4 King G 1
thanks g2 King takes G - mm-hmm page 3
and
kingi one in g3 checkmate
yes now the way she did it is Queen g3
check here here check again if you go
this way the rooks will get you went
this way
checkmate so she brought the Queen first
but the same concept what you did so in
this one in this puzzle what we needed
to see is we need to attack as quickly
as possible because white is basically a
move away from defending everything so
we need to give everything with check
check to be able to checkmate this is a
game between Don chenko and cherish of
chernichaw is very famous for being a
very creative player don't check was a
young Grandmaster obviously his career
just started when he was playing this
game but it's still a very nice puzzle
it's black to move and win yep was the
idea of knights e1
mm-hmm this is a very nice little
double-check you take and now it's
winning otherwise it's quite hard to
stop this idea of night a2 and actually
after night c1 be for would even be
checkmate self mates or helpmate so this
is not too good therefore night c1 is
the winning whoop yeah so this game is
between rugger and McShane Maxine is
known to be one of the best British
players of these days rugger is an
Austrian player so it's black to move
and win
so what what's our first impression of
this position was black what are we
going to play against yeah
I mean we're black so it's black to move
and win so what is black trying to
accomplish in this position yeah
yes so we're trying to somehow get close
to the White King right you have a
solution okay
g4 okay
okay
g4 well I have no choice after go night
c2
g3 I have to take
context
Queen age 6
and it seems that I defended everything
I defended these threats and I'm
threatening to take on the four but the
idea is good we're supposed to meet
somewhere around and do some tricks
around the White King but unfortunately
g4 is a little slow any other ideas
yeah
f3
and if I take this ugly move gtex
what was your idea though
okay because I could see that if I would
take with the night maybe you would try
Bishop III g4 and then maybe this is
even more visible right maybe this was
your idea probably now but unfortunately
I have for you I have this move which
will help my queen to defend my second
rank so it has to be something else
yes okay immediately h6 it takes g3 okay
what if I just take on f5 and if I just
take on f5
yeah yeah G for then that's as you
mentioned is the same thing Queen age
six and actually I'm the one almost
meeting you
so okay now one of them is closer to the
truth than the others
yeah okay very good Queen f6 the idea in
86 which is very nice now we have to
check two main defenses one of them is
to give some cover for the King how can
we defend that white here yeah yeah
Knight f3
now can we refute this Knight f3 idea g4
then then I can even take on d4 if go
here I take on d4 and you don't have
these threats anymore so you have to be
really precise when you're sacrificing
you need 6 yeah not h2 yeah
and I'm out of moves cuz I can't defend
against this one maybe Knight h4 is a
little better but then how we win in
this case
yeah just F takes G three the same thing
and the Queen will take alright so
that's good if this normal defense
doesn't work that's a sign that we're on
the right track now White's tried his
best chance and actually played the move
that gives the best chance for him to
hold what is the best way to defend in
this position yes rook F - well rook
after I might just go half takes G three
go here I might just take and then I'll
do the same thing check check and mate
so you need to find a more radical move
here with light that could give some
sort of hope some sort I mean white
white is losing but maybe this can give
a little bit of hope
so what he played is rook takes f4 which
is funny move especially because if you
would believe that anyways we can play
queen eight-six or we correct this queen
h6 good here no yes
raise your hand if you have an idea yes
yeah Rukh h4 and suddenly this nice
trick works because we can't take
because we lose our queen
therefore McShane found a very very nice
way to win the game he didn't actually
take on f4 he found an even stronger
move here he wanted to win even more
material yeah
but still tell me what you were thinking
I'll rock Dixie one and if I take
mmm-hmm could possibly work but it's
very risky because you're winning right
now you don't need to give up everything
yes Bishop to e3 that's close not that's
not exactly what he played D but had a
similar idea yeah no there should be
five I'll just move my rook away
yes yes so you played Bishop c3 and this
is a very very clever move because now
everything is attacked for White Queen
the knight rook so if you move the Queen
I take the knight and the rook actually
Roger decided to give up the Queen but
that's basically tantamount to
resonation that's why it's good to look
around and not always just take your
opponent stuff but check if you can
attack some more pieces and basically
after Bishop c3 black was easily winning
so in this position was played between
canary and Zhukova and canary who was
always real championship level in
women's chests she actually played a
match with Musa chick even though she
lost but she was always on the top there
and she's facing zhukova was a very
strong female Grandmaster and she is to
move and win the game so it's black to
move and when the first move is more of
a preparation for a sacrifice than the
sacrifice itself it's not going to be
the first move is not a sacrifice that's
what I'm saying
and it's black to move and win yeah hmm
that could work
did you come up late something else for
example like rugby eight if you do rugby
eight then I probably can go be
shouldn't be four and if you exchange
and go here I can take the pawn so
that's why she didn't go this direction
but your idea is she has the same
concept in mind as you but she tried to
go the other way around
so shook ovas next move is more about
restricting her opponents pieces and
that's what she was looking for when she
played this move yes yeah green b1 mmm
it's a good move but that's not what she
played so what she played is like Queen
b1 but a bit less Camaro so she didn't
want to put the Queen in constant danger
yeah
Queen B - yes Queen B - and obviously
this Queen on beats is very annoying so
canary decided to chase that Queen
around but the question is how good will
be for was hinge ooh cava is a really
good idea here
yes yeah Queen take c1 and I take yes
and now it's tough luck for white
because you can't move the Queen anymore
because then you just take the road
right and if you take I take you and
there's nobody going to stop me from
playing rugby one usually d6 would be a
saving grace but does this save the game
any way shape or form really cuz rugby
one comes d7 I take you and I play rook
do you want
and there's yeah well you can play King
f2 but then I just take you anyways yeah
and if d7 then I just go underneath and
I mean oftentimes Bishop f3 is an idea
but then I still have room do you want
because I just promote to whatever I
want
let's make it a row cuz it's funnier and
I just thank you so there's one move
that I want you guys to find just
because that's the hardest way to fight
it's still not good enough
but it's a way to try to hold on with
white what is the best possible defense
here yes
yeah Bishop b4 why is Bishop e4 so good
as a defensive move yeah
hmm yeah so how can we win here with
black
back there how can we win here with
black in this position it's black to
move and win mm-hmm
you know so we just stopped you from
defending the seat upon somehow you need
to get back the control that black yeah
yeah yeah Bishop takes c4 in the same
way
Brooke v1 will work and it's just
winning I mean maybe even rook takes b4
is better because takes takes and this
is supposed to be an easy win because
two rooks against the Queen is much
stronger in end games in the middle game
when you have a queen against two rooks
it's complicated but in the end game and
especially that a king so exposed it's
so many checks possible this should be
lost so it's actually white is Carlson's
second I don't know if he's still
seconding him but he used to be the
second of cosm he's playing share book
so it's white to move and when so as you
can see something's strange going on
with blacks position what are the most
significant things that we can see in
this position what looks kind of strange
can anybody tell me in the middle what's
kind of weird in blacks position hey
what's up
so is this King on f7 actively placed
well you can't go yes and no no well
yeah it's a bit awkwardly placed instead
of well placed so we have it pinned as
white so we just need to use this for a
very nice trick you can actually use it
to give a deadly check
yes yeah yeah rookie four because the
thing is if I take on e4 then I have a
very beautiful check
that's not g5 well the queen is just
hanging but this is maybe the easiest
way even though this is winning but
Knight g5 is also just good enough and
just take the Queen so whenever your
opponent's pieces are a bit scattered
you can expect to be able to sacrifice
the only time it's harder to imagine the
sacrifice when your opponent's pieces
are normal squares often it doesn't work
in that case so it's black to move and
win here even though White's pieces are
normally placed like it's just very very
active
yes
Queen takes f3 mmm
exactly okay
Jetix h3 can get fun
mm-hmm very nice and now black will
eventually win everything on c4 and e2
that's very nice there's actually
another way of doing this Queen f3 is
very nice but you don't have to start
with that order you can also start as in
the game yeah and I teach 3 and this is
the way they played it but actually I
don't I'm not sure that there's anything
wrong with doing the other way around
with Queen takes f3 and if King age 1
how do we win yeah take on f3 takes in
checkmate the same thing just reversed
orders and if King f1 actually you don't
need to need to take on f3 Bishop basics
check wins here
they're very nice little puzzle by
Luther it's another really tricky
position it's black to move and win
seemingly everything is normal but
whites Kings position is a little bit
tricky looking might run into some
trouble
he and hint so do we see some undefended
pieces for white yeah
the rook on c1 in the bishop on d3 so we
supposed to be able to use that
yes 95 but what if I if you go Knight e5
o 95 or if I take you and I take the
bishop but your clothes your clothes try
to find a different move what if it's
not Knight e5 but
yeah
hmm Knight takes c3 because if I take
take what's the difference between 95
and what's the difference between the
two yeah now I'm asking him okay but now
how do you win with black this in this
position you're winning yeah you can go
Queen c1 and because of this enormous
powerful Knight on e3 you can checkmate
so that's why it was a big difference
that you took on e3 and instead of 95
so that means white will have to move
something and after taking Knight c4
Black is just upon up actually that's
not even true I can again go Queen c1
but at least let's say if white takes
like it's just a pawn up but it should
be enough for the game and last but not
least I want to show this one this
puzzle it's white to move and win and
actually this is a little bit tricky
white realizes that one of the pieces
one of one of black's pieces is very
loose and he uses for full effect it
uses that knowledge for full effect
yes yeah in the 8th King hsow yes
now did you find this
mm-hmm so you realize that this night on
h4 is a little bit loose now first you
have to attack it then you have to chase
away the defender and because of the
nature of this position there's no real
good square for black you have to move
the Queen but then it drops and even if
you try to go on the line
I just defend my bishop if you go here
I prefer defending the C pawn just to be
safe and in normal positions when your
opponent has an e4 pawn there's one more
defensive idea that black can use here
what is that and we could normally try
to find a safe spot for this Knight and
where it would be yes
Knight f3 and probably even here
this would be probably the best chance
but unfortunately for us is black you
can just take and now this is just
losing because I can even just check you
and bring the King closer or just go
Queen d2 this is losing so this is it
for puzzlers paradise and I hope that I
showed you that sometimes finding which
pieces are loose are enough to find the
combination that was an example in this
puzzle in the previous puzzles as well
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]